Donald Trump is at Davos I know what is
Davos you ask it's the home of the World
Economic Forum where world leaders and
business executives drink expensive wine
eat fancy meats and throw up in hot tubs
and also tell us what's wrong with us I
was gonna go but my Gulfstream's been
acting up and my manservant Sven has an
infected uvula
but these elites won't be giving Trump a
warm welcome at all and he's already
pissed off the cliffs take a look at
that an angry Mountain Swiss activist
did that pretty funny that there's
activists in Switzerland please their
biggest problem is being confused for
Sweden but it's not like Donald Trump
cares in fact the angrier they get the
more his economic policies stand out but
before those euros go full anti Trump
maybe look at us first our economy is on
fire so much so the Swiss could warm
their hands on it it's cause and effect
because of the lower corporate tax now
even Starbucks Starbucks is giving
workers raises worth millions it's funny
a company raises its wages and Democrats
go silent I guess they just want the
government to make those decisions and
now Fiat Chrysler said the US workers
its US workers will receive two grand in
bonuses this is great news for you and
bad news for all those vulnerable
Democrats up for re-election who didn't
back the bill which means they can't
take any credit boohoo all they can hope
for is a reversal of fortunes that's a
sad place to be rooting for bad news so
you might win might point out that many
of us are wearing burgundy today no
reason why it just happened that's true
it just happened interesting isn't it
yes society no secret society of
Burgundy so Dana I bet you have a theory
about what's going on his first day in
Davos and he's doing great yes indeed
yes and it looked to me like he was
having a good time yes he was so every
time he's gone overseas it's like oh
actually you know what he has friends
he's making friends around the world
making relationships this was actually I
think one of the things that I imagine
that a trump presidency would bring so
he's a disrupter right and one thing I
there's my theory I was gonna say if
Steve Bannon were still in the White
House and advising the president you
think this visit would look very
different that's the tone and tenor of
it would be different the speech would
be different
instead what he's able to do there is go
and say hey I'm the head coach of
capitalism and the world economy is
going well the United States is even
kicking it into higher gear so let's all
work together let's do more but we look
at what all can we do here
I get the America first not America
alone type of thing it's not my favorite
rhetoric but on the other side I think
that the leaders who are there these are
not there's some world leaders there but
there's also business leaders reality
has set in for a long time they thought
well President Trump really doesn't want
to be president right that he doesn't
really want to run again he doesn't and
now they're starting to realize after
the first year that he governs very
differently than he campaigned and that
they're there figuring out a way to work
with him and today there was a
roundtable that he did with some
business leaders and all of them are
like we've got investment in the United
States and we're planning to increase
that and pretty soon all of these
companies there's gonna be so many
companies in America that are announcing
bonuses that if you are the outlier and
you exhaust and you have not announced
bonuses that will become the story it's
[Laughter]
for people like you just easier to say
like which companies haven't gone ahead
and done it maybe the companies are
still thinking about it because you hear
news about it every day no it's it's
such a good point Jesse weird it's like
a weird version of a combination of
trickle-down economics and peer pressure
if you start watching everybody I mean
how can you not deny this cause and
effect it's happening well it's not
trickle-down economics it's more of like
a flood yeah and it's not coming from
the top down it's it's broad-based and
growing out it's not just yes
floodwaters world it's not just a
thousand dollar bonus it some of its
profit sharing checks they're getting
checks $5,000 they're reinvesting in
America there's a also they lowered the
prices of the energy cost at several
different utilities across the country
that's right and some companies are even
throwing money and do college funds for
the workers and things like that so it's
gonna be very difficult for the
Democrats to run again
winning I don't see how they do it how
can you deny your 401k exploiting
haven't you deny tax cuts with their
deniers your bank account they're like
climate denied their winning deniers
it's so easy it's a great it's so easy
and you can see it coming from a mile
away yet not one Democrat voted for the
corporate tax cut yeah
and the deregulation is responsible to
the only way they're gonna have to run
against him is just go super negative
and try to bring out women blacks and
Latinos which don't usually turn out in
the midterms it's going to be it's not a
sure thing putting back the house I'm
stealing winning deniers for my show on
Saturday alright so what I want to play
a sot from another network ah I know but
you got to help these people out because
nobody's watching this is their take on
Trump and Davos and we should point out
one other thing the chair people of
Davos this year this year there are
seven I believe all of them are women
when I look at President Trump right
there I mentioned Klaus Schwab is with
him Jared Kushner Gary Cohn Rex
Tillerson he's ranked almost entirely
well there's one by white guys so on
obviously they have race on the brain
over at MSNBC nothing but white men
clearly this is a racist gathering and
must be stopped
this is almost an outright event yeah it
could be except its overseas right yeah
no I mean you know I think the economy
is going right and I think everybody is
excited and wonderful but if you're
saying that this is somehow good news
that he's at Davos bragging about the
American economy let me tell you there
are several economies overseas they're
doing even better like one oh there's so
many but China is obviously doing much
better and then you go into Europe okay
alright so now we're making excuses
again well ii think like Slater the
American economy is just booming has
never been like this second thing to say
is a majority of Americans credit
President Obama not President Trump with
responsive really Americans Oh anybody
disagrees with Trump is not in the news
kimberley can i play no can I finish my
and then this morning's papers have
Republicans rebelling against Trump
because he's raising tariffs yet aren't
raising prices and people are saying
don't do it and then don't forget the
farmers and others are still lobbying
against the idea that he wants to break
apart math I think that no big apart
race is what makes Republicans honest
because we actually because I have
problems III don't want a protectionist
leader I know I have a theory he's
plenty he's playing tough with these
deals but I think his protection well
I'm just saying you know I just say
there's a lot more to this story about
the economy and the idea that he can run
on the economy obviously if most
Americans think the economy is booming
doing great but they don't credit Donald
Trump that's not good news for
Republican let's see how long they're
able to try to create an alternative
reality alternative facts they're not
except that Donald Trump has actually
done quite a bit here I mean look you've
got a housing rebound the economy is
accelerating jobs numbers up
infrastructure development up there's a
lot of positive things happening here
that you credit President Trump with
including the corporate tax cuts so all
of this is actually positioning not only
the president but Republicans have
something to work with in terms of these
midterm races so he's in a very good
position
he's there in Davos it's fantastic that
the president is participating and
showing up I'm sure some of the people
are quite upset that he's taking a
depressive way from them but he has wins
on his side and he's coming strong out
of this whole battle with Schumer I'm
and Dhaka so you know right now this is
a very positive positioning for the
place you know what I think is the fact
is that what you see at Davos Kimberley
is people who are saying I think the
theme of the whole thing is fractured
you know world but we have a shared
future as in terms of a global economy
and so they are going ahead in terms of
trade deals they're going ahead in terms
of trying to work together
multilaterally meanwhile Trump is there
saying oh no this is about bilateral
agreements with the United States and
he's saying we are putting the u.s.
verse and we are about isolationist
if not protectionism that is not a happy
mess you know what amuses me when the
left said Trump was gonna crash the
economy then the economy accelerates and
they say Obama gets credit for it
[Laughter]
thousand dollar bonus check in January
2018 how is that Obama's by the way I
think the latest polls are 40 percent
believe the economy's better has to do
with Trump and the other ones are split
so it's there's no majority of Americans
there and and for Republicans and
President Trump they're definitely
improving just even in the last four
weeks yeah and part of that is just all
the good headlines but I have a couple
of points one is that for Democrats who
didn't vote for these tax cuts and tax
reform they could this could have been
theirs President Obama did want to cut
the corporate tax rate to 27 the
corporations were excited about that but
he wouldn't budge on individual rates
because he wanted to increase taxes on
the rich so all of this could have been
theirs and the companies that have
announced bonuses imagine what they
would have done okay and over backwards
to try to help and so there was a missed
opportunity the other thing that is it
works in conservatives favor is that you
see some companies pushing to $15 an
hour that was done without the
government telling them that they had to
say so that is another way for
conservatives say that the market works
the the last thing I would say is that
is good for the president to do is that
as he meets with these other world
leaders Theresa May macron and also
Kagame of Rwanda there's going to come a
time when he will have to ask one of
these world leaders and for a favor or
for help and that will be politically
unpopular in their country for them to
do it but if he has personal
relationships with them it's more likely
that they'll be willing to pony up
that's a Salesman you know one last
thing Switzerland big in my belief that
they should not be allowed to have
activists if they are neutral no if
they're neutral they're not allowed to
play
that's like dealing yourself at a
blackjack table without any chips you
know what I'm saying if you're neutral
you can't protest how about that in the
military power I don't know I don't read
a lot Oh
Switzerland or Sweden swear I get them
confused
I know changes them back and one of them
yodels one of them yodels right yeah at
this Swiss yodel and this
we'd fish the fish well don't do it at
the candy all right
I think Donald Trump's gonna come back
with a few Norwegians
[Laughter]